-Performing "This Hell"
from her upcoming new album, "Hold the Girl,"
here's Rina Sawayama!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ahh ♪
♪ Let's go, girls ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ Saw a poster on the corner opposite the motel ♪
♪ Turns out I'm going to hell if I keep on being myself ♪
♪ Don't know what I did, but they seem pretty mad about it ♪
♪ God hates us? Alright then ♪
♪ Buckle up, at dawn we're riding ♪
♪ Walk a mile on these coals, busy cleansing my soul ♪
♪ Getting ready for the night ♪
♪ Damned for eternity, but you're coming with me ♪
♪ Into the afterlife ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ We're burning up together, baby, that makes two ♪
♪ 'Cause the devil's wearing Prada ♪
♪ And loves a little drama ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ With you ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, with you ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ Flame red carpet moment, posing for the paparazzi ♪
♪ What they did to Britney, to Lady Di and Whitney ♪
♪ Don't know why we're here ♪
♪ But might as well get down and dirty ♪
♪ That Satan's looking thirsty, not even he can hurt me ♪
♪ Walk a mile on these coals, busy cleansing my soul ♪
♪ Getting ready for the night ♪
♪ Damned for eternity, but you're coming with me ♪
♪ Into the afterlife ♪
♪ Wow, that's hot ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ We're burning up together, baby, that makes two ♪
♪ 'Cause the devil's wearing Prada ♪
♪ And loves a little drama ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ With you ♪
♪ This life gave us nothing to lose ♪
♪ We're going down together, got a ticket for two ♪
♪ 'Cause the Devil's wearing Prada ♪
♪ And loves a little drama ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ With you ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, with you ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ Got my invitation to eternal damnation ♪
♪ Get in line, pass the wine, bitch ♪
♪ We're going straight to hell ♪
♪ Got my invitation to eternal damnation ♪
♪ Get in line, pass the wine, bitch ♪
♪ We're going straight to hell ♪
[ Guitar solo ]
♪♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ We're burning up together, baby, that makes two ♪
♪ 'Cause the devil's wearing Prada ♪
♪ And loves a little drama ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ With you ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
♪ I'm in this hell with you ♪
♪ This hell is better with you ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Ah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]